stock markets have been tumbling and
President Trump is blaming the Federal
Reserve
he says the feds gone crazy raising
short-term interest rates higher
interest rates not only do they spook
investors but they also make it harder
and more costly to finance the rising
budget deficit so why is the Fed doing
this here's three reasons first of all
inflation has gotten back to the feds 2%
target after running below it for most
of this expansion with inflation back at
the feds target it stands to reason that
interest rates should also be getting
back to normal the Fed kept them near
zero while inflation was running below
target and now it's trying to get
interest rates back towards around three
percent on the short end they're getting
closer to five percent for mortgage
rates the other reason is unemployment
the unemployment rate hit three point
seven percent in September low
unemployment is a great thing for
workers and for the economy but we tend
to see bad things happening when it gets
too low we've had outbreaks of inflation
or sometimes financial bubbles when it
gets too low and the Fed wants to make
sure that the economy doesn't overheat
raising interest rates do that so that's
another reason why they've been pushing
them higher the third reason is that
growth is picked up growth was near 2%
for most of this expansion it's now
closer to 3 percent on a year-on-year
basis what does that mean it means a
stronger economy can bear higher
interest rates so that bed thinks that
what it's doing is justified by the
economy and that it hasn't as the
president said gone Loco